[Música]
olá
estamos falando de conexão e fica
bastante evidente a conexão com o mundo
externo através dos sentidos através da
internet
mas eu gostaria de falar a respeito da
conexão que nós temos com os pensamentos
convivemos continuamente como um fluxo
de pensamentos automáticos que dia e
noite está falando conosco neste mesmo
momento enquanto você está me ouvindo
você pode também ouvir na sua mente
várias vozes outorgando significado ao
que estamos vivendo neste momento e se
pensar automático acompanha você
continuamente e você não tem condições
de silenciá lo quando você se defronta
com qualquer situação
você escuta em frações de segundo o
significado que sua mente atribui a isso
que você está vendo se você encontra com
uma pessoa em frações de segundo somente
ele diz se essa pessoa agradável ou
desagradável a classifica como homem
mulher a classifica como é uma pessoa
com a qual você pode ser comunicado de
uma certa maneira ou de outra
então estamos absurdamente conectados
com esses discursos internos que ouvimos
continuamente e por estamos conectados a
tantos anos há tanto tempo e também
porque nunca talvez não chamaram a
atenção a respeito desse fenômeno a
gente acha que isso é natural a gente se
identifica com esse pensar até o ponto
de julgar há que se pensar automático
involuntário contínuo eu não sou pensar
em você e o pensador no pensamento e
esse pensar volto a repetir é automático
e voluntário e se pensar faz com que
você sinta emoções na hora que você
aceita o pensamento
ele apresenta você não tem como evitar
que esse pensamento geral e moções que
geram impulsos que geram comportamentos
então você fica preso a um comportamento
é padronizado você fica preso a
condicionamentos você fica preso a
padrões precisamente porque você não
sabe o que fazer com esses discursos que
você ouvir continuamente e eu não saber
lidar direito com esses discursos gira
muito sofrimento
por exemplo quando eu era criança era
uma criança extremamente tímida
hoje posso dizer que em função da
maneira como eu pensava os outros a mim
mesmo o ambiente em que eu vivia eu me
sentia inadequado e em função disso
tinha sentimentos de de incompetência e
chegava o ponto de mesmo com nove anos
de idade me esconder embaixo da mesa
quando jogava há algum desconhecido em
casa um amigo dos meus pais
é isso teve um lado muito ruim como
vocês podem imaginar porque era difícil
a socialização para mim mas ao mesmo
tempo tornou esse processo mental muito
evidente para mim era um perigo que eu
precisava trabalhar continuamente o lado
bom foi que como todo introvertido e
gostava de ler e lendo eu vivenciava
emoções mais agradáveis na época eu não
entendia o que estava acontecendo
hoje entendo claramente que estava
substituindo o discurso automático na
minha mente pelo discurso do livro que
irão discurso que sempre termina bem o
herói enganava no final depois de
superar diferentes obstáculos ficava com
a mocinha então dessa maneira vivenciava
emoções diferentes
quando cheguei na adolescência comecei a
ler também livros de yoga e meditação e
comecei não sou ler mais a praticar e
praticar com aquela intensidade típica
do adolescente praticava uma duas três
vezes por dia e aconteceu uma coisa
bastante curioso na próxima
últimos seis meses eu sair debaixo da
mesa comecei a falar e não parei até
hoje e nem porque não conseguia entender
ninguém conseguia explicar exatamente o
que estava acontecendo
hoje consigo explicar isso claramente
vendo a correlação que há entre o
pensamento a respiração e o corpo quando
o pensamento tem o suporte do estado
físico de um estado físico coerente com
o pensamento ele se torna muito mais
hipnótico muito mais envolvente se eu
tenho o pensamento de raiva e meu
coração está disparado tem adrenalina no
sangue
a temperatura do corpo se eleva e muito
convincente ou pensar raivoso
se pelo contrário tenho pensamentos
rigorosos mas mantém o corpo relaxado
tranqüilo o coração batendo calmamente o
pensamento raivoso não se tornar
convincente no meio notícia no meio
possui no geral impulsos no meu briga
agir raivosamente então eu comecei a
interagir mais com as pessoas
isso era na argentina numa época em que
eu fui estudando este ano uma
participação na vida social e política
muito intensa
então comecei a participar do movimento
estudantil é e ao mesmo tempo continue
praticando yoga
só que os dois discursos o discurso
político e o discurso é mais filosófico
do yoga ambos buscavam a felicia
felicidade do ser humano mas através de
e mails muito muito diferentes
no final das contas depois de alguns
anos de militância política eu deixei de
militar e me concentrei mais nos estudos
e nas práticas do ó e eu achei que a
partir daí minha vida iria ser somente
paz e amor mas ser uma época em que os
militares estavam no governo e os grupos
de extermínio estava agindo e
impunemente
então como tinha tido uma participação
política no dia 11
de maio de 1978 um desses grupos entrou
na minha casa rendeu minha mãe meu pai
por sorte não estava na casa no momento
colocou um capuz na minha cabeça e me
levar
fiquei desaparecido há aproximadamente
uns 40 45 dias
e desses os primeiros 36 fiquei algemava
uma parede com um capuz na cabeça
apanhando cada tanto os primeiros dois
dias como vocês podem imaginar foram de
absoluto pânico e terror
diante dessa situação a minha mente só
encontrava é interpretações trágicas
horríveis da situação que eu estava
vivendo ea minhas no estado emocional e
absurdamente é caótico não havia com
quem conversar não podia mexer
praticamente e tinha que ficar nessa
situação
no começo o terceiro dia percebi que
alguma coisa tinha que ser feita porque
não tinha como continuar sentindo o que
estava sentindo
aí tentei fazer os exercícios
respiratórios que a única coisa que
passaria desapercebida que ninguém
perceberia nada de exercícios
respiratórios sofisticados uma simples
respiração lenta consciente com ritmo
mas eu não conseguia fazer mais do que
duas ou três respirações com ritmo
porque porque a mente e possuía
novamente eu não conseguia me
desconectar de se pensar automático que
interpretava que estava vivendo de uma
maneira que gerava todo tipo de emoções
perturbadoras
mas fui persistente e no final do dia já
conseguia controlar a respiração e uma
vez que consegui colocar a respiração
sob o meu controle
lidar com os pensamentos ficava mais
fácil porque muitos momentos conseguia
me desconectar desses discursos que
giravam essas emoções
o perturbadores e por incrível que
pareça a partir desse momento a minha
vivência naquele lugar talvez um dos
piores lugares do mundo naquele momento
se torna uma experiência extremamente e
transformadora porque podia mesmo nesse
lugar tão desagradável vivenciar calma
vivenciar no cds vivenciar serenidade
foi uma experiência extremamente
marcante mas ele um peixinho que eles
pegaram extremamente pequeno tinha 18
anos na época pouca coisa tinha feito
então depois de um certo tempo eles me
entregaram para as forças oficiais e
depois fiquei cinco meses preso em
presídios de segurança máxima para
presos políticos porque naquela época o
país estava com um estado de sítio e o
cidadão poderia ficar à disposição do
poder executivo
depois de cinco meses como vocês podem
imaginar
eu dediquei o resto da minha vida
entender claramente o que tinha
acontecido e aprimorar essa habilidade
de gerenciar esse pensar automático
continuar estudando yoga praticando
estudando e fui pra índia muitas vezes
estive também com monges no nepal na
tailândia na birmânia e nessas conversas
eu descobri que o que eu tinha
vivenciado era uma coisa relativamente
conhecida dos meditadores mais avançados
quem medita com uma certa persistência
segura andrade passa a observar
claramente essa diferença entre si mesmo
e eu pensar automático e não só aprende
a diferenciar os dois como começa a
ganhar a habilidade de mudar o pensar
automático
então o que eu quero compartilhar com
vocês neste momento é que esse
conhecimento a respeito da diferença
entre você ea mente a possibilidade de
estar conectado com o pensar automático
a possibilidade de desconectar se à
vontade e concreta é real é possível e
extremamente útil se você não pode ser
desconectado pensar automático você não
poderia pensar a respeito dele
você não poderia criticá-lo não poderia
é implementar mudanças não poderia
aprender a pensar e de outras maneiras
em certa medida todos nós fazemos isso
mas pode ser feito de uma maneira mais
sistemática através da meditação e só se
torna mais fácil
meditando não inicialmente em branco em
silêncio e discernir entre você
o sujeito ea mente entre o lado
voluntário e o lado automático é
aprender a lidar com esses discursos sem
deixar que esses discursos manipula as
suas emoções e dominem o seu
comportamento
então seja qual for o pensamento que
esteja torturando sua mente seja um
pensamento de tristeza de mágoa de culpa
de raiva de preocupação e de ansiedade
seja qual for o pensamento que esteja
despertando emoções perturbadoras
compreenda isso e é possível desconectar
se esses cursos é possível retirar a
atenção deles e no momento que consegue
fazer isso eles perdem potência eles
perdem força
eles deixam de gerar emoções e impulsos
e comportamentos
você pode pensar as coisas de outras
formas
qualquer evento pode ser pensado
infinitas formas pode ser visto de
ângulos completamente diferentes
não se prenda uma única perspectiva de
vida o que a mente está dizendo pra
poder governador para não ser um escravo
nas mãos dos pensamentos condicionados
tudo que você ouve
ricos da sua história de vida tiveram
alguns sentiram algum momento específico
mas não podem ser o padrão para definir
tudo que você vive
de agora em diante e quando você se
desassociar de se pensar automático você
vivencia paz você vivencia serenidade
você deixa de ter um pensamento modulado
pela sua história de vida e você ganha
objetividade
quanto mais você conseguir se
desassociar do pensar automático mas
conseguirá estar presente mas conseguirá
objetividade para analisar os fenômenos
que têm à sua frente mas estará
protegido protegida emocionalmente de
modo a agir com suavidade de modo anj
com prudência de mudou agir de uma
maneira inteligente então seja qual for
o pensamento perturbador encoraja vocês
a pesquisarem a estudarem e acima de
tudo a praticarem e vivenciarem e essa
desconexões do pensar automático para
poder recolher tratar se com que você
som você não é o pensamento você o
pensador
você não é o significado você é aquele
que define qual é o significado
você não é medo pânico tristeza ou
qualquer outra eu temos um perturbador
você é uma existência consciente e
inteligente em paz você inteligência que
pode pensar todo e qualquer tipo de
pensamento e não tem porque ficar presa
a nenhum deles
pratique leia estude e você poderá
trazer à tona tudo que você carrega
dentro de si de bom de bonito e de amor
os
[Aplausos]